it's too good to pass out I'm gonna show
you guys
well it's kicking my bail let's show you
that show you the window this is the
window where Billy
yes
[Music]
oh hey
big gnarly window
[Music]
let's see if we can hammer bail out
she started
just eater eating whoo just hammer
marnie at 46 inches
getting a little little full bail yeah
so that's for Auster everyone who likes
to run their mouth about Massey Ferguson
mailers which I should say Heston
because it's it they are Heston Baylor's
and Heston Heston knows hey guarantee it
these things are phenomenal Baylor's but
a hussam they all heavy hey so we're
gonna keep just hammer down and make
sure you having backup this is a good
hate building up under my jacket
just another full failing so that's just
just phenomenal then all me and this
whole girl just keep just pushing her in
you can tell there's so much hay there
that were just the feederhouse is
completely fooled because those those
rods that go back in there are just
hitting on that roller just thumping
away
that's just how much haze in there then
it just keeps keeps you in Reno running
we're at four or five mile an hour you
know we're not we're not running no
seven mile an hour but you know I'm
gonna be running seven mile an hour in
this we're just keeping it keeping at it
my goodness
say as much as I can
I should probably go pray
now would've been great for this just
seeing that hey roll through there but
who oh my god are just as tight as we
can get her so
just shelling the day right about and
where I raped
the winners together soon
if you plugged anywhere it'll plug right
here with a swinger Oh separate and
that's just because it'll get a lot on
one side but no it's separated now so
now we're back to these two in rows that
are next to each other so I started in
there I was doing quite a bit of that
Mike man I I gotta get him
I gotta get a video of that so we're
just pumping some numbers so this is why
you know I've got my 8300 my 7810 this
is my bailing tractor my my 7810 I've
got 7800 - just cuz this transmission
right here I pop it out of gear and pop
it in gear just click you know ivt would
be nice - there's got that kind of money
so thanks for watching